the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
this is going to be really informal and
you can try and follow along if you want
I'm just going to show you my basic
workflow from illustrator to after
effects to premiere and like some
important i guess like basic tools that
you might use Elizabeth okay i just
started we finally got everything set I
don't know how did it make it any better
okay okay um okay so first thing is
creating your new canvas so if you open
up illustrator it's just file new um you
can name it whatever you want and then
the profile is going to be automatically
set to one of these options but I adjust
the width and the height to match the
screen size of the video that we capture
which is usually 1920 x 1080 pixels so
you want to make sure the width is 1920
the height is 1080 and the units are
pixels and you can keep the color mode
and the pixel grid the same you press ok
and your screen should look something
like this and and this is just the
drawing surface in which you're going to
work um do you guys want to follow along
or should I just keep going from here
nod
how about sorry can you go through just
like drawing a single shape and then
maybe like draw like a personal space
and then export it out of illustrator
and then animated in After Effects
that's a okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
no worries um so this is just going over
some basic tools I like expanding the
right tool panel just so I can see
everything especially the layers that's
an actual I use a lot basic things that
you're going to use our the paintbrush
this is how you mimic writing on your
tablet so you can mimic your handwriting
you can draw basic shapes with this but
they appear as lines so everything in
illustrator is a vector so this is a
solid object um yeah and then if you
want to make shapes there's a rectangle
tool over here and you can hold down on
it and find other shapes and then you
can just drag to place it if you want to
change the border color or the color of
an individual line you can click on this
this is stroke color double-click and
I'll just give you a full color spectrum
you can select anything and if you want
to change the fill right now the fill
the white box with the red line through
it means that it's transparent but you
can choose any color you want and like
change the shape if you want to draw
freeform shape the pencil tool will
connect lines to make a potentially
solid object so if you want to make like
an irregular polygon or some other shape
the pencil tool automatically connects
them even if you don't completely draw
them together you can also redraw a line
sometimes if you draw them in the same
direction that you originally did so you
can like adjust the border of a shape
slightly what else the black selection
tool can help you select entire objects
um you highlight no no it is it not
recording it was not okay do you want me
to do a quick time recording justice
back up how's it back yeah
ok um ok so the black the black
selection arrow can help you select
entire object so you can drag to select
groups of objects the white selection
arrow you can select individual points
on objects so you can like select a
point on the path and then move it
around so you can warp a line that
already exists and like change its
direction and things like that um we
think the eyedropper tool is useful if
you let's say I was took a paintbrush
and I had a specific stroke weight I had
a specific color that I was using to
draw I don't know a circle or spiral um
and then I reverted back to like black
in one point but I want to go back to
that size and color and the eyedropper
tool will hold both those informations
so if I just eyedropper that then it
will turn blue and eight point brush but
if I drop the black then I'll go back to
one point in black so it just saves you
some time if you want to completely
recreate something the last thing that's
important in illustrator is layers I
usually divided up my project based on
types of objects so if I was doing this
from scratch i would probably put all
the stuff i drew with a paintbrush on
one layer all the shapes on a separate
layer um you create a new layer just by
clicking this the new little page here
and it's basically just a way to group
objects and manipulate them
independently from each other um so for
example i will move this square into
layer 2 and i'll just animate using
layer 2
um and you can toggle and a lock on each
layer so if I put a lock on layer 1 that
means I can't do anything to these
objects like I can't manipulate them
accidentally and the eyeball triggers
whether you can see it or not so
sometimes I you want to draw something
in one layer and then you create a
couple more on top of it and you don't
want to see the original one and I
usually named my lair something to
remind me what they are for the purposes
of After Effects just so it's less
confusing when I get there so this would
be text and layer 2 will be rectangle I
can spell bingo um that's pretty much
all there is to know about illustrator
you can save the files um it'll save as
a dot AI which is important when you
animate something let's save it
somewhere where you're going to remember
where it is and you can just keep the
default settings if okay so here's where
it's going to branch off if you want a
still transparent image over your video
or an animation if you just want a still
transparent image you can draw it and
illustrator like this um just click file
export and it'll automatically go to PNG
click use artboards because that
preserves the screen dimensions that you
specified in the beginning and you click
export and it will give you this pop-up
window and here is where you can choose
whether you want like a white background
a black background or a transparent
which is really nice if you just want
like a text overlay on your video
because you automatically have an image
with vector art in it or vector words
and a transparent background I mean just
click OK and then your image will be
exported I think mines in my downloads
folder yeah just as like a PNG file
which you can import into iMovie or
premier or Final Cut Pro
and overlay it just like another video
track or an image okay that is
everything for illustrator so I will
close that now if you want to animate um
animate in After Effects most likely you
can also learn flash animation but
that's a different concept behind it um
so the way you start a composition and
after effects and import your images
that you started in Illustrator and you
exit out of the initial window when it
asks you to create a new composition
because we're going to just import our
files from illustrator as a new
composition so you just double click in
the project window and I'll give you a
pop-up window that says import file I'm
sure there's another way to do this but
this is just how I was taught um you
probably go file open or something like
that go to wherever you saved your
illustrator file enable all acceptable
files and then import it as a
composition and that just means it will
process each layer in your illustrator
file as a different layer in your
composition which will be important when
it comes to animating and then from here
you can alter your composition settings
tablet aside and
and you can name your composition it'll
automatically adopt the name that you
named your illustrator file and you can
customize the width and the height which
should be the same dimensions that you
specified before you want it to be in
square pixels sometimes it defaults to
different size and I think rectangular
pixels I silly and I mess up how your
video is going to look eventually our
high your animations relate to your
video the frame rate is important
because it allows you to match up your
animation exactly to your video in Adobe
Premiere the frame rate is 30 the
default for after effects is 25 and that
messed me up on my first project because
I was trying to time everything and then
it was off by um five frames per second
which is really frustrating I don't know
what they are for I move your final cut
but I would check when you go in before
you start your project um okay I set the
background color to white just so I can
see everything because I usually draw
with a white background in Illustrator
if you want to set the default
background an illustrator to black and
do white text and set that as
transparent in front of your video then
a black background would make more sense
this background color does not export
with the video though so your animations
are still transparent it's just so you
can see things in After Effects and
usually what I do before I start an
After Effects project is I look at how
long the audio is for the portion that I
want to animate so for example I was
working with Andrea yesterday and she
wanted to go during one of her lines
when she says and the force of a
mountain goat jumping on your teeth is
some amount of Newton's or whatever a
line is and you look at the duration of
how long it takes you to say that line
in your editing software and that's how
long i set my duration of my animation
to be just so it's really easy it's
really like modular I'm animating for
this part of the video and I have this
much space to do it in and because i
don't have an audio track right now i'm
just going to set it to 15 second
so that's good um then you can
double-click on your composition to open
it and this is going to be your display
window this is your timeline it's where
I guess the animation is taking place
and you can see different things and and
here's where you're going to be doing a
lot of the animation stuff this little
options window I guess you can still
toggle the visibility just like you did
in Illustrator and so I let's say I'm
just going to show you how to animate
this rectangle for example so the first
thing you want to do is right click on
it and create shapes from the vector
layer basically this just allows after
effects to take the vector shapes or
objects that you created an illustrator
and translate it into a manipulative all
format and for after effects and so then
you have this new item object I don't
know called rectangle outlines and and
you can look inside and their contents
if you had multiple objects on the same
layer you'd have multiple groups but I
just have the one rectangle so i only
have group one um and so in order to
move this what i'm going to do is open
up Group one and I have different
options and you guys are going to be
doing a lot of transform animations so
these are things like if you want
something to move around on the screen
if you want something to change in size
or rotate or things like that and so
what you're going to do for if you
wanted let's say I wanted this rectangle
to move across the screen and grow
bigger the things that I will end in
After Effects you want to think in
keyframes so what does it look like at
one point in the animation and then what
do you want it to look like in two
seconds um so right now this is where I
want it to start so i'll click ass
little stopwatch on position and scale
and these will set keyframes for both
position and scales
now after effects remembers where the
rectangle is at this point in time then
i'll set it forward to let's say two
seconds i want in two seconds I want my
rectangle to move and then it's as easy
as dragging the rectangle to where you
want it to be and then changing its size
so let's say I want it to be really big
like that and then once you make those
changes after effects automatically sets
another keyframe for you in your
timeline and then you can review what
you want the animation to do by dragging
this back um and pushing space which is
the same thing as play and then you can
watch how over the two seconds it
transitions from one point in space to
another point of space and another set
one size to another size and you can
edit and delete key frames you can add
more in the middle let's say I wanted it
to go up and left before I wanted it go
up and right you can just set it to the
middle of this animation and drag it up
in left to where you would want it to be
and then it'll keep scaling sigh the
size at the same time but then it'll
just adjust its position path in the new
animation and and that's the really the
bare bones of animation the one other
thing you guys might use is let's see
and if you want to group multiple items
and have them move at the same time for
example um see I'm going to take my text
layer create shapes from vector layer
and now I have another layer of objects
um except this one has many contents
many groups of things that I can
manipulate so let's say I want both
these spirals to move at the same time
and I haven't found a better way to do
this but um so I learned that the
spirals or groups two and three I can
click on Khan
just to highlight everything add a new
empty group and it's just labeled
whatever the highest number like the one
after the highest number you can rename
it to something like spirals so you
remember it and you can highlight both
of these and just drag it into the new
group and that way you can transform
spirals as a unit you can see I wanted
them to rotate and so then good okay
that's kind of rotating and so it set
the keyframes for rotations but instead
of just manipulating one spiral I have
to group together and then the rectangle
animation is still going from before
what do you mean with a point AP bone a
pivot point um I think so I don't
usually rotate things in my animations
I'm / let's see I think it's probably
the anchor point
yeah so that's the pivot point I don't
know how to change that necessarily okay
there you can just adjust it in relation
to the Anchor Point so you can change
this value yeah a lot of this is just
playing around and seeing what you want
to do you can ask me questions afterward
and I'd be happy to like troubleshoot it
with you um yeah so I guess that's how
you pivot and so it'll maintain the
rotation just around the smaller anchor
point now um let's see um if this is
might be useful um so if you already go
in and you have a lot of work so for
example in a different project what
happened was I had the outline of a cell
and I was showing contents of the
nucleus and when I screened it to my
project advisor she said it's great but
we're not focusing on the nucleus of the
cell and so I can't really see what's
going on so I had already done all this
animation with individual squiggles of
DNA and proteins moving around in the
nucleus and I want to preserve that
animation but I needed to just zoom in
on everything and you can do this with a
thing called a null object um see if I
remember how to do this okay layer a new
and then a null object and so it'll
appear in here as just no one and
basically it's a way to group multiple
animations at the same time um you can
just leave it name to no 1i guess but so
let's say I want the spiral and the
rectangle to both be smaller because
they're both way too big and so then you
can set these layers as you can set the
null object as the parent of these
layers this is this is parent and you
can have a drop-down
menu and so you can set both these
layers to have their parent as null one
and then you can animate no one as
though it were an independent object so
let's say I just want the scale of
everything to go down so because those
are both grouped under the null layer
then the scale goes down or you can
animate it independently so let's say I
want the scale at a hundred percent but
as the rectangle grows I want everything
to shrink because it got too big so then
you can turn the scale down of
everything so when I run the animation
the rectangle is going to grow the
spirals are going to rotate both on
everything because it's all grouped
under the null layer is going to shrink
um so I guess those are the basics of it
and once you have your After Effects
file and you can I would save it as
something just so you don't lose
anything
and then you can do one of two things um
so if you want to edit in Premiere you
can start um adobe products are really
nice where they auto update to each
other so if you change the illustrator
files that make up the composition and
after effects then you're after effects
will change to reflect those changes so
like if you messed up drawing something
or you want a shape to look a little bit
different um you can up if you update
the illustrator file your After Effects
project will also update same thing with
your After Effects project and premiere
so if I have a premiere project I can
just drag this backwards you can drag
your After Effects composition into
premiere just to import media and then i
have my test animation and i can drop it
here to create a sequence on and so
right now because it's transparent um I
can't see anything but if I were to add
a color match in light blue it's going
to be really garish and add it on the
video layer below the animation then it
will appear so like the animation itself
is transparent if you don't want to edit
and so now if I make changes in After
Effects it'll automatically update those
changes in premiere which I find really
handy as I'm video editing and switching
back and forth if you don't want to edit
in Premiere that is totally fine um and
you just need to export your composition
um I was just playing around with this
earlier usually I don't export so I
don't necessarily have the ideal
settings for it um but we can play
around and see what works so file export
to adobe media encoder
and then it adds it automatically to the
queue and you can choose preset export
settings over here i created a preset
for the edx videos that I'm working on
and so I usually just select that and
then once you do all that then you can
just push play and then the media
encoder does its thing I don't know
exactly what it does i think it's like a
combination of rendering and just making
sure I don't know changing the file
format from a after effects project to
in this case an mp4 file
so you can't do that and stuff like
iMovie so what you will have to do just
interject
and you create the animation and after X
you going from there
footage and then you export that little
chunk yes
would you mind showing real quick
animation
sure let's so it's basically just doing
what I was doing besides and and just
using something besides the color matte
i will see if i have any movies on my
computer I don't know if I do
ok
yeah so the way see okay i have a video
um okay
so the way I would animate and after
effects it's my window still open okay
cool is to use the time codes so premier
has a time code and it's right here and
it matches up with turn up my volume
where the movie is so for example if dry
Kristin so right now like the animation
is overlaid for my movie and the
formatting is weird because I didn't do
the movie first see
okay um what i would do is let's say for
example i wanted at force at five
seconds something to happen like
something to pop up above my hand then i
would take note of the time code or
whenever you raise your hand in the
video so let's say it was at eleven
seconds um and 24 frames um then you go
back into Adobe After Effects and you
can scroll over to 11 frames and make
sure the time code here is listed here
and so you just switch back and forth
and adjust the time code of your
animations to the time code where you
want it to appear in the video and you
can drag keyframes to address that so
like if I say well the rectangle move
too fast in this video and I actually
want the animation to end at 329 instead
of two seconds I can drag my cursor 23
29 and then just drag the key frame to
match it that's usually how I do it just
because it's a lot easier to visualize
and and then it will automatically
update in here and the animation just
got a lot longer and so now when I push
play instead of taking two seconds it's
still going until 329 yeah it's a lot of
plane around I don't have a like a
really really concrete method of doing
it and I'm still learning animation too
so yeah I don't have the perfect answer
but usually it's a lot of switching
between windows which is why when you
have two monitors it's really nice but a
lot of just like checking the timecode
exactly and making little adjustments at
a time first you do it's kind of like
how you edit a movie you start with a
rough cut
start with a rough animation of what you
want and then you can adjust the
keyframes to time it to the video that
you're working with
we'll be around tomorrow but I think the
most efficient route is if you try a
little bit on your own first and then
specific questions papa
yeah and if you have anything specific
in mind that you don't think you can
accomplish with what I've taught you so
far then you can definitely come talk to
me or I can come over and talk to you
and we can talk through what your
picture was for animating something and
how you can best do that either using
the tools that I just taught you or
using other things like I know how to
mimic handwriting to write out a word
and I don't know if that's necessary for
any of you but like that's a thing that
you can do in after effects it's just a
little more complicated than what I've
shown you so far I have two questions
one of these is the I've used adobe
premiere pro before but in the sizing
because I'm not sure when I do in other
big employer looks like the size is
correct however when i exported it to
externally video the sizing more from so
he says a thing for exporting from
premier um let's see
ESP language yes Oh is everything as the
screen that would be shown in the
natural we do yeah so right now because
so what this is I recorded this movie on
my camera on my computer which is lower
quality than the camera than your
camcorders which should record in 1920 x
1080 and so like right now this like
this on this in the upper right hand
corner is what's going to be exported so
the if i exported it right now it would
export with this weird black border
because my video is smaller than this
composition this is preferable to expand
the screen skb I spindle you do it yeah
you can you can individually so if I
take out the you can double-click and
like this is how you digitally zoom
basically you can manipulate just like
any other object and make it bigger so
it fills the screen what do you mean
yeah so whatever you see in this preview
screen is what's going to come out when
you export it and then you can change
export settings file export media and
you can like change the file type that
you want it to be in the video format i
use the settings that mitx needs to
upload usually just because that's it
works and it produces a high enough
quality video but if you know things
about audio and video and things like
that you can add like a copyright
encoded into the video itself if you
really want to protect it and things
like that but last necessary
I think it's 30 i'll double check it
and if I want together yeah but video I
took a video yep by the moment I want to
cut the frame and extended for you to
make it like a picture well I stay the
concert yeah um so this is something I
can I don't know how to do it in final
cut I know how to do it in premiere so
hypothetically in premiere that's a bad
friend cause that's a helmet pause this
frame um you can do like there's a
button here it just as export frame I
click it and then it's uh what do I want
to be it's like still face it's an I
just wanted a JPEG I guess um and then
this box just means it you import into
the project automatically so no matter
where it saves it in this case it's
saving it in my premiere folder and
click OK and then it automatically
appears as an image in your media
browser area and so then if you want to
extend this frame what I would
personally do is use the razor tool cut
the clip into to use the selection tool
and drag this over so I have some space
to include it and then include the still
image and then just seal that gap back
up so now instead of just seeing me talk
and I should have brought it closer but
then I'll talk I'll talk I'll talk and
then the still frame will happen for
like however many seconds you said it
and you can adjust the size and timing
of that and then the video will resume
when you're ready for it to be
but a key opens video up in time
and I'm doing it so yeah good how are
there any other questions about
animating or editing or Adobe I mean
where does yeah I'm around for the rest
of today so if you just put anything up
here and work where you want to go back
to the classroom and work yeah mm-hmm